Hi everyone, welcome to Introduction to Gameplay in Unreal Engine 5 for Programmers.
In this talk we're going to look to cover the following topics.
We're going to quickly recap some of the content from our previous talk, that being
the Introduction to Unreal Engine 4 for Programmers.
We're then going to look at the gameplay systems that Unreal Engine offers, both the
out of the box solutions and also the gameplay tools that we can use to build
our own solutions.
The out of the box gameplay systems that we're going to look at are the gameplay
frameworks, that being the pawn, character, controller, player state and movement components.
We're then going to look at animation, the game world setup and inputs, followed by
delegates and events.
We're going to briefly take a look at some of the helper libraries that Unreal
provides, followed by serialization and programming subsystems.